most smart people over time realize that
possessions don't make them happy now a
lack of material possessions can make
you very unhappy yeah so being poor can
make you unhappy but being rich is not
going to make you happy and what happens
unfortunately a lot of people struggle
through their whole lives to make money
they make some they're exhausted and
then they're like well now why am I not
happy I guess I'm just not a happy
person and smart people aren't happy it
comes from if you're smart it's usually
because you thought things through and
you have a very busy mind yeah and so
busy mind can often rob you of Peace of
Mind the peace that we seek is not peace
of mind it's peace from mind right so if
you look at all the crazy activities you
do to be happy right whether it's like
trying to get laid and have an orgasm or
you know extreme sports or looking at
something beautiful or taking a
psychedelic you're trying to get out of
your own mind you're trying to get your
monkey mind to stop chattering at you
for a moment you're trying to get peace
from the mind and there are other better
ways to do that